منذ ايام خرج التسريبات من اسبانيا
لمقتطفات من مذكرات الامير هاري سبير
ولحقت بها ثلاث مقابلات تلفزيونيه اخرها
لقائه ببرنامج جود مورنينج امريكا نستعرض
اهم ما جاء فيه اعترفها لان دوره وترتيبه
في ولايه العرش ربما هو سبب التنافس
الغريب بينه وبين شقيقه الامير وليام كما
يعتقد ان شقيقه يشعر من غير منه لانه لا
يملك الحريه التي يملكها هو يقول هاري ان
الصحافه كانت لها دور اساسي في الوقيعه
بين اسرته واسرته شقيقه وعامل على تحريف
ضد بعضهما البعض يقول انه لم يخطط هو او
زوجته لتركه منصه بهما ملكيه وانما اعتقد
انسر هي المكان الذي سيقضيان فيه بقيه
حياتهم لكن بالطبع تبدو العوده غير مراجعه
الان يشعر الامير هاري بالراحه بعد صدور
مذكراته يقول انها الطريق الوحيد لصنع
السلام واي ان يعمل ان يساعد على حمايه
ابنائه والاجيال الاصغر من افراد العائله
الملكه هل يعتقد ان النظام الملكي
البريطاني يجب ان يستمر وان هناك مكان له
في القرن الحادي والعشرين بشرط ان يكون
اكثر عصريه واقل انحاذا